après les moutons qui remplace les
tondeuses voici les biquettes qui
recycle vos sapins ou plutôt qui les
mangent direction 11,1 dans le loir et
cher là-bas une ferme récupère les
arbres de noël pour nourrir ses chèvres
adieu la corvette déchetterie pour les
particuliers les chèvres elles raffolent
de cet aliment naturel
audrey champigny
à la ferme de la cabine est c'est un peu
noël après l'heure pour cette vingtaine
de petites chèvres
eric est allé bic est alors avons mangé
les les aiguilles là ici avons mangé les
bourgeons c'était c'est très très riche
et avons déshabillé les petites branches
ainsi tout le long de la journée
on entend que ça croustille au bout
d'une journée
voilà à quoi ressemble le sapin pour ses
chevrettes il s'agit d'un complément
alimentaire naturel
en plus du foin et des granulés salon
ramène des oligo-éléments donc entre
autres la vitamine c la vitamine b pour
leur croissance basses qu'elles n'ont
beaucoup besoin
et puis bah nous après derrière on a
c'est pas aussi d'autres produits pour
les pousser
autre industriel quoi jusqu'à fin
janvier didier loïc devrait récupérer
près de 300 sapin de quoi faire la joie
de leurs 4 1 puis on compte deux sapins
pas par jour
voilà en est sûre ce qu au mois d'avril
avril mais en avoir quoi en revanche les
chèvres gestantes elles sont privées de
sapins nocifs pour la santé de leur
foetus dans quelques semaines maintenant
elles mettront bas le lait lui servira à
la fabrication de fromages et autres
produits vendus sur l'exploitation